a babysitter accused of killing a child
remains in jail tonight a lot of viewers
responded after the i-team first broke
the story back in march
vanessa murphy continues to follow the
criminal case and also has more about
what unfolded in court this morning
now we do want to warn you the details
in the story are of a disturbing nature
lauren courtney appeared in a courtroom
here at the regional justice center
metro police say she beat a child to
death while
babysitting him and it was caught on
video
lauren courtney
22-year-old lauren courtney faces murder
and child abuse charges
a prosecutor saying in court tuesday
she's now received
autopsy results for five-year-old ryan
james peralta
which could result in amended charges
the child died on march
12. according to this arrest report
courtney told police
she babysat for ryan and his
seven-year-old sister since
august ryan's father had installed
cameras in his home
after his daughter said courtney hurt
ryan while at work
he received a call from courtney that
ryan wasn't doing well and he was
coughing up blood ryan's dad returned
home to find his son
unresponsive on the couch detectives say
courtney was angry the child
urinated on himself and she is seen on
video
dragging ryan while he was limp kicking
him in the head
dropping him so his head hit the
bathroom floor
punching him in the face and dragging
him into the shower
the report states she turns the water on
as ryan cries and moans in pain
during an interview with police
detectives describe
courtney as showing no emotion and say
she claimed she has mental health issues
she's expected to be back in court on
august 12th
i asked courtney's lawyer if she'd like
to send a statement
on her behalf and she declined reporting
in downtown las vegas vanessa murphy 8
news now